[Music]
welcome to fat man be out I'm Kevin
Smith holy [ __ ] man we are in Vancouver
British Columbia the gorgeous Rio
Theatre put your hands together the
folks at home know you're real it's so
appropriate that we do the fat man
beyond here man because like I've
previously just heard I saved at the
theater you're right yeah sorts and
stuff and it was very nice I saw last
week I think it was the Rio put up
pictures to a few people that let me
Ryan Reynolds put out a tweet and stuff
like that Seth Rogen put out a tweet I
showed up and did two [ __ ] shows so
now for nothing I may not be a native
son of Vancouver but I beat both of
those Fox and so in any event they took
pictures of in the back or somewhere
there are seats that have aren't front
row is that where they are where are
they somebody sitting in the Kevin
Smith's you you you my friend are
sitting in the cabin Smith's seat guess
what you win a joint no this is
Vancouver you find that anywhere I need
these very lovely man it was quite an
honor and stuff and hun I'd dig this
theater I'm so glad it's safe there's
very few art houses left in the world
and not only can you show flicks here
but you could do [ __ ] like this you can
do all sorts of wonderful things with it
so that's what hopefully the ladies will
continue to do give it up for a man they
saved the REO okay I've been up in
Vancouver now for the last like about a
week I guess it's coming up on I am up
here not just because I love the Pacific
Northwest and rain but I I came up to do
my fourth episode of Supergirl which is
quite thrilling for me I've never done
four of anything no um I had one well
technically I guess one misadventure
yesterday on the streets of vacant
Vancouver and stuff you know me I'm a
fan of the green right yes the Irish
I'm yes absolutely love them good people
potato eaters and stuff so in any event
I you know I I just that part of the
story is relevant and and disconnected I
just wanted to say that now this is a
story about me and my car has nothing to
do with that okay I'm gonna put the weed
back here yeah the same keep it it's
just something for the background of the
story so as I'm driving home I take
Hastings the Hastings exit and I'm going
down Hastings and stuff and I'm I'm a
pretty easy to get along with in every
[ __ ] area of life except on the road
on the road I'm an absolute [ __ ] I
Drive it's all the worst characteristics
truth yeah is nasty I'm just so bad it's
a it's like it's like me versus are you
Fox I don't know where it comes from
just dr. Jekyll releases Hyde and he
drives and [ __ ] so I was driving with
you is like we're gonna get to Valhalla
shiny and chrome he's really [ __ ] soon
I reach into the console and pull out
the spray paint [ __ ] get ready we're
going down Hastings showed up meat bag
and it's I love you know Canada I'm on
record is love in Canada but [ __ ] these
people drive slow and so there's just
patient with each other that's it
they're not slow they're just courteous
like I can't tell you how many people I
watched stop and like let somebody go
and I'm the guy right on their a scone
as if like my father was killed by a
[ __ ] Dark Jedi or something like that
who drove real slow yes
so I was driving and you know I wasn't
driving and Hastings was pretty busy so
it's not he couldn't be driving too
recklessly although I was bobbing and
weaving through traffic so we were
stopped at a light and then the light
turned green and I went through the
light and all of a sudden a car broom
turned on its lights but it was what I
used to call undercover but
Tyler today gave me the term ghost car
he said as a ghost car and which sounds
way cooler it's a cop car but they
weren't like it's an easily identifiable
cop car it was undercover and [ __ ] like
it wasn't like a taxi no it wasn't that
undercover it wasn't a transformer they
were just driving an unmarked car March
unmarked something nobody ever wants to
be so I see the lights come up and I'm
like oh [ __ ] and I have my seatbelt on
which is [ __ ] rare for me but I'm
like I figure I'm in another country I
better obey their laws and [ __ ] and so I
wasn't worried about that so they come
up to the car and I had my license pull
my line I went into above compartment
and they had like the paperwork cuz it's
a rental car and stuff and so I see the
one officer lady officers coming up on
the right you know how they do they both
creep up on the car and stuff to make
sure that you're okay and so that's
that's the idea so he approaches my
window gingerly and stuff and I'm kind
of already holding out my license and in
that paper the one paper that was there
and so he take he goes hello and I said
hello give him paper and he goes a
rental car and I said yes and he looks
at my license and he goes oh you're that
actor aren't you and I didn't know what
to say because I'm like well not if you
read my critics no not at all and then I
thought does he think I'm Kevin James
which happens a lot you know more than
you would imagine now I was in Burbank
not too long ago and some [ __ ] I was
getting out to go to a deli and the dude
pulled up to a stop sign he wasn't
driving it was the backseat dudes
hanging out the window and he sees me he
goes oh oh
Kevin James and I go no no no not him
I'm the other one and the guy looks at
me like this and I go lay a Remini and
he goes like that and they take away you
know
but he goes you're you're the actor
I said yeah sometimes and he gives me my
license to goes get out of here and so
you know rather than just be like yeah
yes sir 10-4 good buddy and [ __ ] pull
out and [ __ ] I needed to know why I was
pulled over yeah I was telling Bob the
ad the story and you know he's gone I'm
sorry so you wanted him to come closer
to your window and have a conversation I
was like I hadn't thought about that
but I was just like why and like just
out of curiosity what did I do wrong and
he goes no it's not that he's gone were
were this and he points to his chest and
it says like drug and Drug Enforcement
gang Patrol something like that so he
goes where this and I go oh and he goes
we're looking for rental cars like the
dealers use rental cars and you have a
rental car we're looking for a drug
dealer I didn't have the heart to tell
him he pulled over a drug taker and so I
was like oh good to know thank you and
then you know but actually I waited for
them to go I'm [ __ ] smart and stuff
and so they pull up and then the lady
officer who hadn't gotten involved in
stuff but she was back in the passenger
side of that car she pulls up beside my
car my windows open and she rolls down
her window and she goes you're not our
clientele and then they [ __ ] off man and
my heart was like pretty [ __ ] awesome
pretty sweet I I never tire of hearing
white people's super rosy interaction
with the police
I want to know why they pulled me over I
have more questions for you officer now
don't go away get your [ __ ] ass back
here and tell me what's wrong with me
I have follow-up questions
look please become an actor
please become an actor Kevin Hart I'm
like Kevin Hart but just as tall a
little bit heavier it's fine it's fine
it's fine ten and two tentative yeah I
guess my experience is a little
candy-coated isn't it I'll tell you
about the time I got arrested driving a
rental car the Fox series don't ever go
to Daytona Florida and you could drive
on the beach in Daytona Florida what
yeah you can like you could just live
there's a there's an on-ramp and you can
just there's a bunch of [ __ ] cars
driving on the beach you can pull off
park your car and just walk into the
[ __ ] surf if you want because it's
Daytona Florida everything is legal and
so I rented this Volvo shiny [ __ ]
Volvo in like 1993 well that was a
banner year for race in our country oh
it was it was so me and my man my white
van girlfriend are driving in my Volvo
in like the belly the cradle over the
south and I just hear and yes officer do
you have any knives in the car do you
think like that's your first question
you have a knife in the car no I don't
have any nice how about a gun
what a good would you like to see my
license all right I guess and so like I
gave him my license and he goes back to
the car and my girlfriend is like what
the [ __ ] is going to who are you look at
a [ __ ] drug you know I've been Dana's
guy over nine months now we're getting
arrested in Florida and he comes back
and he says well you you you didn't buy
insurance in the car and you have a my
license had been randomly suspended it's
another long story but so yeah so you
you don't have permission to drive this
car we have to
rest you now it's like well my
girlfriend can drive the car it's not as
if we're gonna dyke break more laws by
driving or even though no we gotta take
you in
they put me in the back of a cop car
they cuffed me they drive me in till I
[ __ ] [ __ ] me yeah they drive me to
the Dade County Jail house and they
leave me in there for 10 minutes while
they process my bail which was 50 bucks
but I spent you know half an hour in the
backseat of a cop car and then 10
minutes behind bars and did not tell my
in-laws that because I then married that
lady for 20 [ __ ] years so it took you
20 years to tell you a story about me
dating your dog by the way I'm not sure
up twice it's fine she's not going
anywhere
today but when I was arrested did she
bail you out no I had 50 bucks on me all
right host no bounds that how it works
you can give be like he seems like so
couldn't you just give him 50 bucks on
the beach and call it quits
well then it's a bribe in jail it's bail
I'm sure with the same [ __ ] place if
you're an alien watching us can you pick
up the subtle difference between the two
I mean we're all laughing so I don't
know if you could yeah really the
response is the same well yeah I gotta
have to fly back down I was living in
New York tonight to fly back down to
appear in court to get it dismissed off
my record because I think it was just a
misdemeanor but I didn't want a [ __ ]
record I might run for president never
gonna run for president but I just I
didn't know it twenty years old what I
was gonna [ __ ] do right so I flew back
down and had it expunged I guess was
that the only time you're ever in jail
well I mean I had toured Alcatraz so I
like stepped into a chance hell you're
not Nick Cage dude what you been up to
man I've been up here doing that I did
take a trip I've been back to America
since I've been up here and I snuck down
over the weekend - this is so stupid but
I [ __ ] love their food at home I've
been home for a while in Los Angeles
usually I'm traveling and stuff but I
was home for like a good long month
whatever and so I fell into the steady
routine of like every day around noon or
1 o'clock I go to veggie grill this this
restaurant
that's near us as a vegan joint but it's
delicious it's [ __ ] good and it's
still plant-based and stew [ __ ] so my
[ __ ] kid can't give me [ __ ] and what
no I'm still staying I'm walking the
vegan path and I hate [ __ ] vegetables
so much man like I used to be happy and
I'm a [ __ ] vegan but I've found like
I found like ways to do it without
actually eating vegetables all the time
and stuff so you know there's like beans
count like you know if I gotta eat a lot
of chickpeas peanut butter and jelly
that's also vegan and stuff so you know
that's my been my [ __ ] path and [ __ ]
and I eat that same meal over and over
and over again when coming up here
suddenly I was like oh [ __ ] they don't
have veggie grill in Canada like they
got now Vancouver is great for vegan
restaurants they got vegan restaurants
out the wazoo and stuff and a lot of
them really great but you know I was
eating I was like that was my meal and
suddenly I was like what's gonna happen
man if I get rocked off my meal like I'm
I gotta gain weight again and [ __ ] cuz I
was like literally reducing while eating
food I enjoy and I got worried and then
I was like well I'll do it for Supergirl
and so while I was up here I looked up
there's a veggie grill there the only
been three states right is in California
Oregon and Washington so they got one in
Seattle so it's like two and a half
hours away I said to my wife she came up
with me for prep and [ __ ] and I was like
let's do a [ __ ] like a Smokey and the
Bandit cross-border run for some [ __ ]
veggie grill she was like are you
[ __ ] serious you're gonna drive two
and a half hours to get that [ __ ]
food I was like it's good food [ __ ] you
and so thus began a married road trip
together and we drove down to the
Seattle and stayed motel overnight so I
could eat it twice so I could have it on
Saturday we'd go to sleep and then I get
up and have it again on Sunday the
premise was you know I was gonna go down
there to write because I'm working on
this other thing and stuff and I had to
do it finish a draft a bit so I was like
we'll go right there is easier to
concentrate without all this rain and so
and so we went for the veggie grill run
and then when I was there before I came
back on Sunday I want to eat again and
it's like when I eat there I literally
it's [ __ ] crazy my wife loves it
because I can't help but it's like when
my cousins used to eat cereal when I was
a kid
irritated the [ __ ] out of me they would
eat cereal they go exist nom nom nom nom
they [ __ ] literally nom did the whole
[ __ ] meal whatever they nom nom they
said the word [ __ ] nom and [ __ ] never
I never stopped my cousin still does it
this days [ __ ] 45 nom nom like they
were just taught that way chew with a
word and [ __ ] onomatopoeia right there
in the meal so this veggie grill
experience for me when I eat when I bite
in the beyond burger it doesn't matter
like who's there I swear to is always
the same and it cracks my wife up
because it's I don't even think about it
just [ __ ] happens naturally but my
eyes roll back in my head and I'm like
and she goes that's your [ __ ] face that's
how good a veggie grill is man so and
she would know so so I brought veggie
grill back with me I was like I didn't
want to go crazy I was like can I get
three I'm gonna get three beyond burgers
I'm gonna get three orders of veggie
nachos but don't bond or nachos but you
can't put them together because it
should have good soggy
I need containers in the queso and then
I need the beans over here and then
chips over here and [ __ ] like that and
god damnit man
if this kid wasn't like [ __ ] on it
look he understood he was like you're
travelling right I said yeah two hours
man I was like a candy goes you don't
want it soggy I was like I don't you
understand and he built it perfectly
very rarely especially like you take
something on the road like I didn't
check it because I can't like I'm
definitely afraid of rudeness I hate
offending people right so I wouldn't
never look in the bag in front of him
see if he got it right and [ __ ] and I
didn't even think to do it when I got to
the car I didn't check till I got back
home to Vancouver he packed this [ __ ] so
well and I was able to bring veggie
grill three days well two days in a row
tomorrow's my last day that I'm [ __ ]
out of it and [ __ ] what are you gonna do
I don't know I'm thinking about like
busting out of work early for another
run to the border and she
you're talking about a five hour round
trip but [ __ ] that food is good man like
and I don't have much in my life anymore
you know they took away all the fun food
so the one thing I eat it's within two
and a half hours and I'm like I could
make it I can make it so they are open
till like 10 o'clock at night so
conceivably I could leave I'd like five
and [ __ ] and when I get to the border
they're like what are you doing I was
like you really don't want to know it's
gonna be disappointing a spot it's not
weed I swear it's I'm going for veggie
girl have you ever heard it it's amazing
I I did a road trip like that once for
Dunkin Donuts which it's like Tim
Hortons but better oh my god you'll lose
Canada forest take it back
nothing beats tea hose they call it
Timmy's up here Timmy's Timmy's but no
we call it Duncan or now just today they
announced they're dropping doughnuts
from their name what what else do they
think we're gonna get their coffee
[ __ ] but they can't like doughnuts
makes people go off doughnuts oh I can't
eat a doughnut that's unhealthy so now
they're going from Dunkin Donuts they're
just calling it Dunkin
that's like KFC will never refer
themselves as Kentucky Fried Chicken I
think that's mostly because it's barely
chicken I think they're trying to hide
the fried part more than anything else
maybe but yeah in LA there hadn't ever
been at Dunkin Donuts or a Dunkin or a
DD or whatever the [ __ ] you want to call
it but they opened one in Barstow
California which if you if you don't
know how far that is from LA it's
basically like driving a Thunderdome
it's in the middle of the [ __ ] desert
Air Force Base that's kind of decrepit
it is the worst part of Los Angeles
it looks like the Salton Sea it totally
is just everything out there is dead you
know dead and on smack so my wife was
super [ __ ] homesick and we found out
they opened one she's like we're going
I'm like it's 2 or 1/2 hours for a
[ __ ] donut I don't care you want to
be married
alright I guess we're [ __ ] car we're
driving and so we drive to enough hours
for Dunkin Donuts which is not as good
as Timmy's
I gave it to you and we rockin 400
[ __ ] Donuts what because if you're
gonna drive two and a half hours for
[ __ ] Donuts and they don't go bad
like that's true it's not like I got a
Porsche in them out I gotta cram them in
will take three dozen donuts that means
you can whip them at each other you know
what I'm saying that's enough donuts -
were like passers-by
it's like crawler and if they if they
think fast enough if their reflexes are
quick enough they're rewarded with a pay
scale Avengers day thank you sir carry
on up here whenever I do the shows I
like to go to tea hose and buy we did it
the first time we did it was on my
second episode of flash I can't remember
but maybe was the first episode of Flash
Malcom my friend Malcolm my Canadian
foreign Malcolm's from the other side
from Toronto he'll be out sooner or
later and stuff he's making a
documentary about me right now that's
what Malcolm normally does he makes
documentaries about gay themed subject
matter now he's got the gayest theme of
all me so Malcolm Malcolm was [ __ ] what
story was I gonna tell I just hit a
speed donuts thank you speed buzz
pothole Malcolm one day I was like hey
man like we should bring some [ __ ] in to
eat it was for the production meeting
was about to happen the production
meeting is we're sitting around with all
the heads of the departments and stuff
you literally go through everything in
the [ __ ] script and stuff and it's
it's it's kind of boring it's very
clinical and it's a necessary process
but part of the process everybody knows
that on the same page everybody has
their [ __ ] covered and whatnot but you
know it's [ __ ] cannabis news so I was
like [ __ ] you know it would make it
better
doughnuts let's bring some [ __ ]
Timbits man they're like munchkins from
Dunkin Donuts and [ __ ] so I said don't
you speak donut I speak doner
so I said to Malcolm I was like let's
get some [ __ ] Timbits and stuff he
goes yeah yeah let's get some [ __ ]
treats that'll win everyone over and so
I said well how many Timbits do we get
he goes how many people in the [ __ ]
meeting and I was like I don't know
seems like about 20 or something like
that he goes well you get [ __ ] two
50s and I was like what do you mean few
guys I got a box of 50 you get two of
those it's a hundred and I was like what
if we got a thousand
and he goes I don't even know if that's
possible
I was like we'll call up call up Timmy
Hortons and see if it's possible and
stuff so I was on the witnessing end of
the phone call I saw him calling up
Malcolm is so boisterous and so like
[ __ ] definitive and the loudmouth
about [ __ ] like he's so like he's
dialing going we're gonna [ __ ] get
these Timmy's man they're gonna make us
a [ __ ] thousand because that's what we
deserve [ __ ] [ __ ] these [ __ ]
yeah hi I just wanted to it goes into
the nice Sal mode he's like I was
wondering if it's possible to get a
thousand Timbits and it's quiet he's
like huh huh
yeah cash okay yes thank you bye and he
goes you can buy anything in this world
I was like a thousand Timbits he's like
we're getting a thousand Timbits and I
was like how much was it and it was
[ __ ] criminally low dude it was under
I can't remember what the figure was but
it was under $200 and I was like a
thousand Timbits for under $200 why
haven't we've done this every day like
you could [ __ ] get fatty and embeds
and we did and then you'd have so many
left over you just have an office
[ __ ] Timbit fight man so we got a
thousand supers like what does it look
like and you go and it looks like a
[ __ ] thousand Timbits it's
essentially twenty of those box of 50's
so as much as we were curious what's a
thousand Timbits gonna look like the
people Megan the Timbits we're so
curious what we looked like who the [ __ ]
and then when me and Malcolm both of us
big as houses walked in there like that
[ __ ] figures so he said this is for
fall ash and they're like oh whatever
you know and so we brought them to the
production and [ __ ] and they were like
flabbergasted like what's this and I was
like this is a thousand Timbits and so
we got a bunch of bowls and [ __ ] and
arranged it to put it out there and -
everyone took pictures because nobody
had ever seen a thousand bits together
at once you could have charged admission
look at the Tim [ __ ] for $10 you can
eat one I kept telling him how impressed
I was that it was under 200 I can you
believe this is only under $200 and some
people looked at me like you've lost all
value of money
but that seemed cheap a thousand of
something for under $200 like what does
that work out to be two bucks a Timbit
no that'd be wrong I'd be way over
charged 20 20 cents 10 cents
I guess 25 cents man like for 20 cents a
day you could whip a Timbit at a friend
did you when you were all done because
I'm sure you didn't eat all those timís
did you make like a devil's tower out of
timber no we brought it to set and so we
brought it to the rest of the production
we were like we brought you Tim bits to
the actors and we didn't we brought him
for production upstairs and [ __ ] but the
actors you know actors are like normal
person walks into a room sees a [ __ ]
bowl full of apples normal people says
Oh somebody has left a bowl full of
apples on the table that's nice actor
actress walks into room sees a bowl full
Apple said Oh somebody left apples for
me and [ __ ] Texan so that was what we
did with the Timbits put him out there
and they're like this for us was they
good sure are and they [ __ ] scalped
them all up couldn't eat them all man
like we were given Timbits away at the
end of the day like take these home to
your kids and people like [ __ ] no but it
was pretty amazing to see I'm a bum a
donut fan myself who isn't I don't know
if I'll be doing it this time those a
vegan it goes against you know all my
principles now I'll be bringing treats
like who wants snap peas they're like Oh
fun calves gone used to be all doughnuts
and bagels now it's [ __ ] this [ __ ]
well at least that's better than
bringing them like vegan doughnuts cuz
nobody wants a vegan doughnut yeah
that's true
that's like an insult cut doughnuts yeah
remember how we used to be delicious
[ __ ] that but no Arnim animals harmed in
the process just humans you ready to do
a show we can do a show [ __ ] let's do a
show this show ladies gentlemen
is comprised of two very important parts
man the first part of it is mr. mark
barnard
who has been an editor for such
legendary outlets as The Hollywood
Reporter Entertainment Weekly the Los
Angeles Times he is a newsman by trade
who is now a screen writer by trade as
well but he spent so much time in the
news we send mark to go [ __ ] bust
open the news and mark busts open google
and then found out a bunch of [ __ ] for
us to talk about so give it up for Mark
II dug up some news I still have my
Stetson hat with the press thing in it
and open reports don't like a Walter
Winchell so hey I did not think in my
entire life I would have a week where we
were discussing Batman's dick nearly as
much as we've been discussing Batman's
dick this week my my brother of all
people [ __ ] texted me the other
morning to say something of the sort he
was you know my brother text me about a
number of [ __ ] things of course but
never about this sort of thing we find
it real quick
Donald wrote did not think I'd wake up
to see the Caped Crusader's Dick Grayson
lol and my brother is a gays the day's
long he's been married to his husband
Jerry for well as oldest clerks was the
same year of clerks of 25 years man and
[ __ ] so this was you know Batman I could
talk about Batman you know tell him blue
in the face and his eyes glaze over he's
very patient he'll just listen to [ __ ]
but Batman's dick on the table my
brothers like tell me about Batman so he
said to you that I didn't think I'd wake
up seen the Caped Crusader's Dick
Grayson lol and I wrote bat-pole cowled
monster caught crusader his super friend
the Knights dork
the whole internet went crazy coming up
with battle Hwang was pretty good whoo I
like that one
Bruce's Wang is pretty good you have a
favor uh no no I'm bat dick says it all
that dick really does I was just more
curious about the conversation of
whether he was Jewish or not why is that
is that a deeper conversation well
because is he circumcised or not right
you said that with a lot of confidence
man [ __ ] yeah it's been in my mouth at
least he said he was Batman his name was
Bruce but like name was Bruce a bunch of
[ __ ] are out they would like
like Jewelers loops examining the
[ __ ] panel but I think that's it's is
that cup I don't know well maybe the
Joker had strapped him down and did some
awful [ __ ] to him when a magic
circumcising machine people are [ __ ]
writing fanfiction about how Batman got
cut late in life yep whoa like Batarang
accident grappling hook and malfunction
I've seen the picture it was more of a
shadowy outline like the ladies
indicates it was very disappointing I
was I was looking to see thick veins and
[ __ ] like that maybe a tattoo Martha
down the side usually just MA and then
you get the full Martha later I don't
know I saw that picture man you could
fit Thomas and Martha on that [ __ ]
they didn't know they weren't shy about
give him a big fat dick
you know in really in reality though
don't you think it'd be the reverse the
guy that's like I'm not jump off
buildings beat the [ __ ] out of strangers
must have the smallest dick in the room
right but instead them of course it's
huge it's Batman god damn it why don't
you ever share with everybody else here
and there's Superfriends well for
reasons I don't I just um private I'm a
knight
you'll see my bat ham where's the
fritter yeah man
first off let's have a brief discussion
was that even necessary I don't think so
because really the internet was not the
world it was not asking to know what
Batman's dick looks like I just think
the line moves an awful lot a few years
ago I did a Batman story where Batman
talked about wetting himself and not on
purpose and it sounds more juvenile than
it is it was built into a retcon a
little bit of the moment in Batman year
one where he lights off the grenade
blows out the wall and says to let
Gotham's elite good evening you've eaten
you know ladies and gentlemen of Gotham
you've eaten well but tonight that ends
and blah blah blah it's a real great
[ __ ] moment in Batman year one so we
were telling he's telling one of the
characters in the story I did that story
and so kind of mimic that same [ __ ]
gorgeous David Mazzucchelli panel and
stuff and he talks about like you know
at the thermals went off and boom the
wall explodes he's like what I was not
prepared for it was the intense blast of
heat the wave of heat that I'd be struck
with and this is [ __ ] scientifically
true friend of mine Brian Quinn from
[ __ ] of Impractical Jokers
before he was a TV star he was a fireman
Brian Quinn told me like sometimes we
rush into a building BAM you open the
door you're hit with the backdraft not
so much the flames but the intense
[ __ ] heat that comes off you [ __ ]
let go you can't help but it's not like
you wet yourself you just involuntarily
[ __ ] pause it just hits your body
saying why you're going to shower and
it's hot and you're like ah you start
taking a leak imagine
that's not you I I should know not to
share your house yeah you'd stop at the
toilet and then if I can use the showers
happily it's all a drain
I'm not saying [ __ ] in the shower even
I've got to cross so it's like that he
said but it really intensified so I was
like oh that's good to know
so I wrote it into the scene and the
scene Batman's trying to like relate to
this [ __ ] person and Batman's like
not able to relate to most people
so his inner conscience like just
[ __ ] share tell him he tells him that
story and stuff so in the you know after
the comic came out that's I took a
beating on the internet and still have
periodically there's a Twitter account
that does like factoids or whatever [ __ ]
and the fact will come up Batman once
wet himself in this miniseries and then
people who tweet it to me and go thanks
[ __ ] so I'm the guy that made Batman
wet himself supposedly and and and
[ __ ] the guy that showed Batman
schlong he should be in way worse
trouble than me mine's based on [ __ ]
science his is based on a dream well and
biology Batman's got a dick will that
help sales of the book
I think it has especially certainly
created attention for it pretty
attention and they're in reprints
they're going to erase Batman's dick so
is that right yeah they're going back in
subsequent print loans will no longer
have Batman's dicks first appearance and
so it'll be cut from there forward
circumcising the appearance if you will
why so they were all ballsy until the
world was like yeah yeah and it never
stops and then that awesome once people
go hey well who what do you think was
the argument that made them go I [ __ ]
will erase it in the future
I don't mean just I'm sure public
pressure just why did we have to have
this and I'm sure parents got involved
I'm sure kids got involved
I'm sure Warner Brothers got involved
and says hey so you know Batman is like
a billion-dollar franchise for us maybe
don't show people is dick because that's
not gonna help us sell [ __ ] underwear
ironically to children yeah so that
means this won't be a growing trend of
[ __ ] superheroes with their dick
swinging it should the like in the next
issue of Wonder Woman well remember
Marvel used to do swimsuit issues
remember that back in like this yeah
yeah but there were these like hey so
there's [ __ ] Logan just a ball of
puffs of hair and then like a thong and
just like what why why did cables cables
I don't want that it's true made you go
snikt alright fair enough man so bat
dick we're done with it will it ever
come back to haunt us will it ever rise
again bad dick returns The Dark Knight
Rises yeah I I don't think I think this
is a bold experiment in in testicular
presentation would you say that it was
successful yeah it seemed like a gimmick
that did not gimmick the way they wanted
it got him a lot of attention man
I'd like light night talk shows we're
talking about it Seth Meyers did bits I
mean if the light even go press is bad
press Maxim holds true then yes it was a
win but I still didn't really want to be
talking about Batman's dick today and
here we are it's not like my brother
yeah speaking of Batman did you see the
the Joaquin Phoenix test footage from
everyone seeing the image of Joaquin
I mean it's crowd clearly apparently
they're shooting where are they shooting
that picture in the Bronx right now
there was a student in New York yeah
interesting so they're shooting out
definitely in the real world wherever it
is apparently the Bronx and when you do
that that's that because everyone's got
a phone in their camera in their hands
into all given times and whatnot so even
a non-professional person Blanca Paz
like oh [ __ ] there's a camera oh [ __ ]
there's a clown oh [ __ ] it's the Joker
BAM you're gonna have it spoiled like
crazy so in an effort to combat it or
since images are getting out there Todd
Phillips the director of the movie this
stated like look they're putting out all
the paparazzi putting out bad pictures
at least I'm going to put out good
pictures like if the image is going to
be out there let me share good versions
of this so because of that we're seeing
an
an amount of material on this movie
while they're in the earliest stages of
production including the look of the
Joker's something that nobody ever
really saw bless you on dark night until
very close to the first trailer like
there was no very early image of each
Ledger out there in the world so it's
it's it's crazy but at the same time it
does fuel interest what do you think
about the direction they've taken with
it so far it looks like they can't say
for sure we've seen the be-all-end-all
version the character because they keep
doing iteration zuv him in clown makeup
I am still not certain that this movie
needs to exist really it's still
starting to look kind of dope but like
the more I see the more curious I am
yeah you know like Batman's dick you
just want to know more how long's this
been going let's shed a light on this
particular shadowy figure yeah like I I
I just I mean we talked about on podcast
before I've put it on Twitter like I the
Joker's not a thing that I need an
origin story for you know like without
Batman I don't understand what the Joker
does I don't understand what his purpose
is there-there the twin poles of the
same particular universe and without one
you don't get the other so why are we
only gonna get one and not the other
that said looking at Joaquin Phoenix and
their makeup which seems to be like both
a nod to Heath Ledger and a nod to Cesar
Romero and a little bit of a nod to the
masks from from The Dark Knight yeah
like it's it's it's unifying a lot of
things and and I think that there's a
woman which the Joker is our generations
Hamlet and that every great actor wants
to take a swing at it hmm
you know and like what's what's my
version of this thing we're gonna say
pretty much the same lines and do the
same stuff but how do I make this a
unique creation compared to everything
that had come before and everything that
came before was brilliant you know Wow
Wow
and there's that one yeah but it's true
it seems like the role where people like
oh I mean I could [ __ ] make minced
meat ooh this I get to go crazy and
stuff yeah fair enough fair enough I I
mean look he's a great actor I'll watch
him do anything
seeing him take on this role I'm been
curious from the jump but I'm also of
the belief that you could make a bunch
of these they can make six Joker movies
I'd see all of them half of them will
probably be really good so you know I
they're not planning that but they are
they were talking about making this one
and the Jared Leto one it feels like the
Jared Leto one quietly goes away based
on this one Jared Leto's agent ladies
and gentlemen yeah I mean I I hope it's
good it looks interesting and I will
take interesting um where I don't think
Suicide Squad for me looked interesting
it looked messy but in other Batman news
okay birds of prey is a movie they're
legit gonna [ __ ] make they have a
release date now February 7th 2020 Wow
they're starting to cast the other
actors and there's a bit of a rather
than calling it birds of prey they're
calling you birds of prey and the idea
is this is the ladies of Gotham movie
right so it's it's what your face is
coming back Margot Robbie's coming back
that's right like when they are looking
to casserole of the Huntress and the
candidates are sofia boutella from the
money Oh Mary Elizabeth Winstead oh
let's see Oh
USS callisters Cristin Milioti the girl
who played the lead in that yeah yeah
close was she and I saw her she was in
How I Met Your Mother for a little bit
yeah yeah yeah and and Margaret quale
who was in the leftovers and she's now
in Once Upon a Time in Hollywood that
Quentin Tarantino joint know so they're
all up for the Huntress for Renee
Montoya they're looking at once dated
which Huntress do you think they're
gonna do I don't know Helena Bertinelli
no connection to Bruce Wayne you know
the character originally started as
she's the daughter of
man and Catwoman on earth three for some
such [ __ ] probably not that no they're
not doing that yeah that's a guess right
now Montoya is gonna be in it they're
looking at one-day-at-a-time Justina
Machado and an actress named Roberta
kalindra is from Vita she's a lesbian
detective from Gotham City's police
force according to the press release for
Black Canary they're looking at Gugu
mbatha-raw who it's like she's [ __ ]
stunning she was in bail she was in
under the lights she was in Doctor Who
for a stretch and another actress called
a jurnee smollett bail from underground
so Black Canary is going to be a black
lady oh wow yeah so uh a little on the
nose but good yeah well progress well
done every other black character you can
play the black man so that movie's gonna
happen
damn movie's gonna have who's in charge
they say director and Kathy Yin oh I
don't know what she did before but yes
she's the third female filmmaker in the
DC fold bi have had a doozy of a
Duvernay who's doing new goods yeah and
so this seems like it's closer to going
the new guts though right I think so new
god seems to be like Ava's currently New
York to shooting the Central Park five
miniseries for Netflix she doesn't seem
to be actively in New Gods world but who
the [ __ ] knows I don't I look forward to
this movie in a big bad way man you
could do cool things with this and
they're doing it in the shadow of the
bat as well so you don't have to include
that character necessarily as a main
character but he should make an
appearance and if he is making an
appearance which Batman would it be oh
yes god damn it you just made my dick
hard
if it was jon hamm they were like look
we're gonna do a stand-alone man just
like Joaquin Phoenix is the Joker in
their movie we're gonna pick on Batman
in its Jon Hamm holy [ __ ]
I would pay twice but are they gonna
make him show Jon's ham truly is it on
driver yeah man they got to include
Batman in some ways it'd be weird to
have everything happening in Gotham like
oh he's on vacation this week but I look
forward as [ __ ] to that movie men can't
believe I remember I had a you know uh
ladies of Gotham print from the Warner
Brothers store years ago the hung on my
wall that had most of those characters
and it's like it's nuts to think that in
the mainstream like my mom is gonna know
oh there's a movie with Harley Quinn and
it will she'll know that cuz your
granddaughter sure but she'll be like oh
my god there's a movie with the Huntress
in it who is the Huntress tiger and then
I'll tell her I'll sit her down and be
like oh ma
well on her three it was Batman and
Catwoman daughter but they're probably
not gonna do that I'm ready for that I
think DC needs to make more movies more
and more and more movies he's talked
about them making more Superman last
week that just wound up in the press
cycle - this show is interesting as [ __ ]
man like whenever we do an episode when
the episode drops there's always a
series of news articles that spin out of
it and and sometimes it's not even news
like I saw people going like what a
delta headline was like Kevin Smith
thinks fan os-- is a hero wasn't the
case and stuff I just put them on my
team just to beat mark and [ __ ] but they
could really spend a lot of news stories
out of this which is funny because we
just read other people's news it's like
fourth generation news it's barely news
anymore we ate half of this [ __ ] up but
now apparently it's pressed it counts so
there was a every quarter or so they do
investor calls at places like Disney
we're let's say you're an investor in
Disney you want to know what the [ __ ]
doesn't he's doing so the head of Disney
guy named Bob Iger will get on the phone
and just he'll investors throughout the
country and the world what
and he was asked is Kevin Feige going to
be overseeing the x-men universe and his
quote was I think it only makes sense I
want to be careful here because of
what's been communicated to the Fox
folks but I think they know it only
makes sense for Marvel to be supervised
by one entity there shouldn't be two
marvels
that's good news so BAM well number one
it means that like you know the things
we've been hoping for are gonna come to
pass they're gonna Kevin Feige and the
Marvel Universe kind of get to play with
those toys sooner rather than later some
person suggested on Twitter today maybe
you know they've talked about like
infinity wars going for reshoots and
people like reshoots why why some people
on Twitter were like maybe they're
adding X characters or Fantastic Four I
was like could you imagine oh my god but
I'm already like they don't even have to
do it I guess on one level you could be
like how do we top killing half the
Marvel Universe by bringing them back
and bringing in like [ __ ] look at the
x-men even though we've seen him a
thousand times this is our X bad now the
better x-men well I mean we had always
talked about the the reversing the
[ __ ] snap as some kind of like
backing up time or reinstituting
whatever but it could also be a parallel
universe where we're importing old
versions or different versions of those
characters who already love right
they're being yanked from their time and
put into sort of earth prime time yes
and if there's a parallel earth in the
Marvel Universe that parallel universe
could be the Fox universe and so along
with the parallel universe black panther
in the parallel universe whatever those
characters could also get stuck in the
[ __ ] drift and suddenly there's
Fantastic Four suddenly Reed Richards
talk and [ __ ] yeah like you
could if you wanted to do that you could
do that you could if that's gonna be one
of the routes you could [ __ ] pull it
off I don't think that that's part of
the reshoots only because not to say we
would have known right but secrets are
incredibly hard to key to anymore and if
[ __ ] secrets great like you know
they're they manage they keep secrets
from the [ __ ] cast when I interviewed
his vision and the Scarlet Witch Paul
Bettany and Elizabeth Olsen I was at a
con in Seattle and I interviewed them on
stage they talked about they didn't find
out the scene where [ __ ] spoilers
vision you know dies and [ __ ] they
didn't find out yes all right they
didn't find out until the day they were
shooting that scene so they were pulled
in she said they pulled them into a van
like a panelist windowless van down by
the river oh my god they're like kids
here's some candy get in the van pulled
him into the van shut the doors and told
him like this is what's gonna happen and
so they had like about an hour to
process it and figure out their
performance and boom they went at it and
stuff so they keep [ __ ] quiet from even
the people in the movies and stuff they
do but like if you're going to recast
the x-men which I'd have to think
they're gonna because why honor all
those Odile's why why bring the baggage
of those characters and those iterations
even Hugh Jackman do you say goodbye to
Hugh Jackman yeah cuz he Jackman has
said like you know if they could ever
cross over the x-men and the Avengers I
will be back like he said he would do it
in a heartbeat but since you're kick
starting a brand new like iteration of
the Marvel Universe that does include
the X characters including Wolverine do
you want a younger Wolverine I think you
want a younger Wolverine that's gonna be
it's gonna be an interesting it's gonna
be interesting kind of impasse for for
Disney uh yeah well they did old man
Logan but it's gonna be interesting to
see it felt like because the fanbase is
gonna want to see Hugh Jackman he's
still alive he's expressed interest
isn't blown out his heart by Jackie how
much he's in the best shape of his life
is that the height of his [ __ ]
theatrical the cinematic box-office
powers right he's coming off of that
movie Bradley sure made a showman and
stuff so it which made a lot of money I
mean you don't have to like it but it's
[ __ ] like that was a movie that
everyone in the business was like this
movie's gonna [ __ ] tank it ain't
gonna make jack [ __ ] and it made a [ __ ]
ton of money and made him look really
smart had a few great songs there is a
ton of [ __ ] residual love for Hugh
Jackman for sure and I love him as Logan
how do you get over that though howdy in
the same reason that I don't want to see
Harrison Ford ever [ __ ] do Indiana
Jones again I just don't like I give I'm
if I'm gonna live with another cycle of
these movies if we're gonna have Indiana
Jones for the next 50 years yeah you
have to replace that guy if they're
gonna make the x-men part of them all
the universe you cannot have a 50-year
old dude as your Wolverine you just
can't do you think they should do the
old Fox at all or just be like we're
just starting our own continuity we're
not not like where we [ __ ] don't
acknowledge that [ __ ] but technically
they're like that's not part of our
story I mean they don't acknowledge Eric
Bana at all you're right remember those
[ __ ] irradiated dogs know what
irradiated dogs next yeah holy [ __ ] man
all those Fox people are Fox like we're
gonna make a Marvel movie kimbugs like
no you're not
naw [ __ ] take care don't they have an
x-men movie coming those Dark Phoenix
right yeah so they're gonna release that
they are gonna release it and then we
will never see those people again yeah I
mean I guess like I'm of two minds of
course I love you Jackman and the idea
of seeing him play with like Tom
Hollands spider-man and Robert Downey
jr. [ __ ] Iron Man is is enticing as
hell I guess we should see like Kevin
Feige hasn't let us down yet you know
what I'm saying like he's not made a
[ __ ] wrong call in that universe yet
so at that point if they decide like
look we're just gonna bring you all new
x-men oh [ __ ] I forgot about Deadpool in
Vancouver I forgot about Deadpool what
do you do that's right [ __ ] you can't
like leave debt that guy behind like
particularly that iteration is working
insanely well yeah what do you mean
Kevin Feige here ladies and gentlemen
yes he could break the fourth wall
that's absolutely no I think you keep
that dude yeah because I think that a
he's behind a mask for most of it but be
it's so indelible to that aside from
Logan really none of those air the
characters are as indelible in those
roles I mean I love Fassbender I'd
[ __ ] love McAvoy but it's still not
Ian McKellen and and Patrick Stewart and
you still replace those guys that's true
and we did get used to it yeah so we're
gonna get another one
we're gonna get a whole all-new exponent
was all-new all-different that's
exciting
on some level look I've just it's
exciting to see them play in that
universe so far they've done [ __ ]
great and that's exciting and that's not
even including Fantastic Four all right
what else we got
let's see hey you like the game of
thrones right [ __ ] yeah I'm just living
- Game of Thrones that's it man I
survived the heart attack so I can get
the [ __ ] Game of Thrones I got to
know what happens to things on Game of
Thrones front yeah one I saw Dan Weiss
and and I felt Benioff and Weiss in my
office because the mark works as a show
called Treadstone I work on a show
called Treadstone which happens to share
the same offices with one of the dozen
places the Game of Thrones is doing
their post work so every now and again
we will just hear like dragons roaring
somewhere in the office and like but I
saw the two show runners Benioff and
Weiss in the men's room the other day
did you they went together well they
work well together really dude they go
guess they keep it going to that bath
tick or what just hold each other's
dicks for they just stand in front of
the urine or the like jerk arse
[Laughter]
so yes any any ongoing some at all no I
would say hey nice dragons good to see
you're not unsullied it's good so that
happened but in Ireland they are now
going to do for the game of Thrones
sets what they did in New Zealand for
the for the lower of the ring sets which
is now too [ __ ] tourist attraction
you can now go or at least in 2019 you
can go and visit King's Landing you can
want to visit the the Watchers on the
wall you can go and visit Castle black
you can go and visit Winterfell how
they're going to keep all of the [ __ ]
that they built up and running it's now
going to be like a [ __ ] walkthrough
museum oh sure yeah
so if you want to go to [ __ ] Ireland
and pretend that you're you're taking
the book the black you told again I'm
gonna do it black taking the black I
want a t-shirt why are you happy about
giving up sex well just for the [ __ ]
picture man no well yeah they are super
excited about having a tourist
attraction that's not Guiness to make
people come to Ireland and it's
beautiful I know now we have this but
yeah so that's happening starting in
2019 [ __ ] a I won't go to that I've
seen the show I'm good and I know what
sets look like they're [ __ ] fake they
are yeah it's all lies and [ __ ]
unless they were like come take the tour
we'll show you a real [ __ ] dragon then
they got my [ __ ] money man you don't
know unless you go it's true
were you a kid who watched well knowing
your love of sports were you we were
Space Jam fan I am the big Looney Tunes
fan why are you Space Jam fans
I was a big Looney Tunes guy so I did I
did take the journey with them to Space
Jam I remember when they first started
teaming them up with athletes Chuck
Jones had done a series of collector
cards Bugs Bunny and the Looney Tunes
characters baseball and and then slowly
like they did those commercials like
with Bugs Bunny and Michael Jordan and
then suddenly the Bugs Bunny and and
sports brands were intertwined and [ __ ]
and that have resulted in Space Jam
which I did pay to see in a movie
theater and you know and enjoyed I was
just happy to see the [ __ ] you know I
like those characters a lot and and I
loved the fact that they tried again but
you know it's some [ __ ] then [ __ ]
translate very well and so you know I
figure I'd never see another Space Jam
in my lifetime we saw the one and only
Space Jam that's what you think my
friend they're making another spaceship
they are making a really Omega LeBron
James is going to be the star of sense
Space Jam - okay Ryan Coogler
is producing space jams - you have my
attention
really really write this first thing
after Black Panther is like imma do
basketball movie with animated creatures
because everybody loves all of these
things that is a crazy kind of like I'm
so successful Black Panther was so
[ __ ] successful let me do the thing
that nobody would ever [ __ ] let me do
in a rational world they're like what do
you want to do we'll let you do anything
he's like Space Jam - this one's gonna
hurt but here's all the money I didn't
see he was in trainwreck right LeBron
James yeah and really really good isn't
he a voice and small foot or big foot or
whatever [ __ ] that's called uh maybe no
I don't know I saw a large voice cast on
that the Bigfoot cartoon movie that's
coming out smullin he is the star of the
show
small small foot is that what it's
called Burt
not of his LeBron Jameses foot what the
[ __ ] is huge weight the premise of
this movie I saw the [ __ ] trailer
small foot is a human being like the way
we think of them is like the big foot
they think of us is like the small foots
and they find a [ __ ] small foot now
you don't have to see the movie
it's like Tarzan but with human it's
really a pun more than anything else
like hey man what do you think the
Bigfoots call us small flood go make
that move it's a hundred million dollars
but yeah so Kugler is gonna gonna
produce it I got em Terence Nance is
directing who created HBO's random acts
of flyness
oh okay which is a super [ __ ]
interesting show you've watched it I've
seen two episodes of it what is it about
it's like it's like black black mirror
it's an anthology it's it's sort of
anthological but even in any given
episode they episodes are like 45
minutes long there's eight or nine
different stories there's a bunch of
[ __ ] vignettes but it's all kind of
about the future and the
african-american experience and half of
its animated and some of it's weirdly CG
and some of it makes no sense of them
it's all the sense it is just this weird
kind of fever dream of a TV show Wow
it's interesting I don't know if I like
it I like that it exists right because
it's [ __ ] weirdest [ __ ] and we don't
get enough weirdest [ __ ] on TV so yeah
I'll take some weird [ __ ] but why you
get that dude to be like you know we
want you to do weird a [ __ ] guy Space
Jam too we got that guy he just made 2
billion dollars and we were - [ __ ] dude
and LeBron James meant me some [ __ ]
money yeah somebody's gonna make some
money there I'm just happy to see the
Bugs Bunny B characters coming back out
of hiding yeah there was a there was a
great onion tweet that was like Kevin
Hart shows up on Space Jam assuming he's
been cast as a voice
[Laughter]
that's my Kevin Hart everybody bad not
bad very good
so yeah we get one of those
Kingsman three got a release date
they're making a Kingsman three for real
I got to tell you man I enjoyed those
both Kingsman movies I mean naturally
the first one was surprising and out of
the blue so it was an absolute and it
was just so [ __ ] up like you're
watching the movie and all of a sudden
she's like if you save us I'll give you
a no I'm like did I write this and then
the second one was also like a like
totally fun and watchable although the
the Western guys weren't in as much as
you thought they were gonna be based on
the trailer right but I enjoyed both of
those Matthew Vaughn did both of them
you didn't do this third one's coming
back for the third one I think he's
[ __ ] talented man he makes really
good movies I've talked about before her
like at one point I was in England when
they made a kick ass and they shot it
over there they shot it in England and
so we shared an agent and my agent was
like hey man you know Matthew Vaughn I
was like not personally but I know he
makes movies who's Bruce or now he's a
director it's like he made a comic book
movie I was like what one he goes kick
asses go shoot he made the kick-ass
movie see yeah he's having a screening
would you go would you go to it tonight
as I would love to and he goes I want
you to go to it and I want you to like
find cuts for him and tell him what to
cut out of the movie and I was like oh
all right fair enough so I went to the
movie and then after the movie you know
I've ended and it was a little bit
longer than the one that everyone else
saw on stuff out lights come up [ __ ] and
there's Matthew Vaughn and he's talking
to everybody everybody like you know it
was only about 25 people in the
screening or something small screening
room and then you know I'm waiting till
everyone's gone then I was like hey man
I'm Kevin Smith he's like hey and I was
like so Phil told me like to tell you
the stuff to cut so let's this is what I
saw I think it is great movie man like
really fun like [ __ ] that [ __ ] with
it girls insane but in the beginning
like there's some kind of and I start
going in my cuts and the guy looking at
me like [ __ ] off that was like good to
know and so sugar zan and [ __ ] left
and stuff and I called up fellows like
you embarrassed the [ __ ] out of me man
so I like him as director I think he's
really [ __ ] good this Kingsman movies
been fun to watch he's gonna do a third
I'm going to do the third it's it'll be
out on November 9th 2019 which was when
bound 25 was gonna open oh and they
moved and they knew that they he took
that date
it's a little cheeky yeah it will be
according to von the conclusion of the
Harry Hart eggsy relationship ah we
thought that had concluded in the first
one but then the movie did well and no
let's bring him back and give column
first one it's not dead nobody's dead
you know I just remember seeing the
second one and it was the it was on the
heels I think like a month or two after
Prince died and so yes and and Kingsman
2 was the first movie that's not a
prince movie to have a prince song in it
and I remember sitting there in the
entire opening [ __ ] car chase and
said to let's go crazy and I was like
why is this so [ __ ] amazing oh [ __ ]
it's Prince yeah that never would have
happened back in the day he never
allowed that stuff to happen and it went
and his music wound up on Spotify and
hadn't been there as well and a bunch of
it ended up on YouTube and they pulled
almost everything off of youtube like
you could never see it's true he would
he would actively oh yeah he would go in
and just start mouthing in [ __ ] and so
you could never see legally his Super
Bowl halftime show no it's which if
you've never seen is phenomenal in
playing purple ran in the rain and
[ __ ] like covering Foo Fighters yeah
just cuz he wanted to and didn't tell
the Foo Fighters and so the story is the
Foo Fighters were like watching the
[ __ ] game and someone is like Dave I
think Prince is doing one of our songs
[ __ ] Prince is not covering our song
clip oh [ __ ]
he's no better than we pin it huh oh
should we pay him enough man all right
where to next last story is that story
of the night molested a little bit of a
sad one Gary Kurtz who produced among
other things Star Wars and Bry strikes
back American Graffiti and the Dark
Crystal Wow
passed away last week after a fighting
cancer for by
year how old was he was but 78 years old
the facilitator of our childhood you
know it's George Lucas of course is
credited with the imagination and
whatnot but like somebody has to make
that [ __ ] happen it's easy to write you
know [ __ ] the droids land on Tatooine
it's somebody's actual job to figure out
what the [ __ ] is a Tatooine how do we do
this and he was the guy yeah he was he
was the executor of that vision he's the
one who like George invented it George
wrote it george cashed it he summoned it
into being so george could shoot it it's
true the the the the director the writer
these are the sexy roles that are
fetishized they're easy to identify and
understand for people outside of the
industry right like because they've been
told over and over again with that job
is and i would still argue that
qualifying the job of director is really
difficult and not because it's a
difficult job it's just so weird if you
stand outside of a movie set or TV set
and you watch it operate you can pretty
much qualify everybody's job you like
that person is holding a pole with a
microphone on it they must be recording
sound this person has a camera she must
be the DP this person is doing this
everybody's jobs easily quantifiable
these people are standing in front of
the cameras and pretending to love each
other or hate each other they must be
the performers and stuff but if you were
to sit outside and look at the director
you'd be like there's a guy sitting down
watching television everyone else is
working he don't do [ __ ] what's that all
about and then it take ends and you see
him go over and like whisper some [ __ ]
to people and then walk away and they
just do it again and stuff it's a really
weird job to kind of [ __ ] qualify so
this job though on the other hand what
were we just talking producer producer
thank you that job is [ __ ] really
hard to [ __ ] communicate in a big bad
way it's always been tough to figure out
like what a producer is especially
because there's so many different kinds
there are some that are just big name
producers that [ __ ] attach talent and
[ __ ] like that but you know if you were
like make this movie he gave him a
script you know with a gun to their head
you'd [ __ ] fire the Gunks they
wouldn't know how to [ __ ] do it
then their producers who probably
wouldn't kill him that's just an example
the an [ __ ] yeah untrue the producers
that are nuts and bolts that actually
make the [ __ ] happen build it from the
ground up and whatnot Scott Mosier was
that person for me in the
getting in my career the guy who I'd be
like I want to do this and you'd be like
all right let's figure out how to
[ __ ] do that
this guy was that for George Lucas and
you know the person that producer
doesn't get a [ __ ] ton of credit and
usually it's an easy roll to joke about
and stuff but a really wonderful
producer and nuts and bolt like a kind
of line producer type producer you can
hand that person man or woman a script
and they could [ __ ] bring it to life
for you so as much as people let go like
oh that director they make the movies
that I like and [ __ ] like that
the director is like you know who I like
the person that facilitated that because
if I was left to my own devices it would
just be a script sitting on a desk
somebody smarter more talented than me
is the person to figure out okay we're
gonna need this this this this this and
I'll find money sometimes so this was a
guy who you know that name is writ large
and my childhood Star Wars was where I
first started paying attention to the
credits of something I was seven years
old and the movie meant so much to me
you just wanted to know what the [ __ ]
was going on and who was involved so all
of those names are rockstar names of my
childhood like David Prowse and [ __ ]
like that but Gary Kurtz was always one
of those names his name's his name was
on some of the movies that shapes who I
became that I watched over and over and
over again and would even watch the
credits at the end even though it wasn't
a Marvel movie and there was no [ __ ]
action happening and [ __ ] you just
watched out of a sense of like I love
this so it was a name I grew up with and
yet oddly enough like not one I've ever
liked I never sought him out or anything
like that but he was just part of the
fabric of my childhood swear to hear
that he's gone yeah the thing there was
that I found interesting there so bid
that I pulled off of deadline is that he
assembled the second unit crew for
George Lucas on Star Wars and he himself
directed most of the the cockpit
dogfighting scenes so all of the actors
during the [ __ ] trench run he
directed those guys so it's so he
directed stay on target he directed stay
on target
he's coming you're all clear kid let's
blow this thing and go home he wrote the
most pornographic line and stones
so yeah Heder and George is very famous
for like he's not the actors director
yet more faster more intense yes the two
things George would tell people and so
my favorite moment in all of Star Wars
the Euroclear kid let's blow this thing
and go home was him Wow so thanks Gary
Kurtz yeah that's true man give it up
for Gary Kirk the magician behind the
magician he'll be missed all right man
that's it for the news that's the news
give it up for mark he brought us all
through the new second part of this show
ladies and gentlemen it's Q & A that's
where we open it up to you folks in the
audience and we takes questions man and
me and Mark here try to answer to the
best of our abilities generally speaking
when we do this show at the scum and
villainy Cantina most of the questions
come from a bunch of people who want to
be in the industry or on the fringes of
the industry people want to do what
we've done and stuff so we're able to
kind of give them the benefit of our
experience one we don't put on airs and
they say we know anything or everything
but we can certainly tell you what we've
been through and stuff like that
and if it helps your journey toward
artistry all the better so we open it up
to Q&A what we normally do is give out
tickets to the winners whoever asked a
question was a great question we give
them tickets to a 40x theater but they
don't have a 40x theater up here so we
can't give you tickets that but what I
did instead was I brought some is a
little more personal but it's a little
weird but I'll walk you through it on
the plants I brought five t-shirts but
they're my t-shirts
I've been going through a bit of weight
fluctuation lately so some of the
t-shirts that I used to wear like don't
fit anymore so what you'll be getting if
you win if you ask a question and it's a
good enough question to warrant a prize
I don't know if it's a prize but you'll
be winning one of my old to excel
t-shirts they've been washed so they
don't smell like me and [ __ ] but I bet
you like if you got a gene splicer you
can pull DNA off these [ __ ] and
make another Kevin Smith so what we'll
do is we open it up five questions all
we ask is the question has to relate to
both of us it can't be something like
hey man what's going on with Jay and
Silent Bob reboot because that's the
question that only I could answer and
stuff so it's something that both of us
can answer if you don't if that's not it
then you don't win a t-shirt you should
like yeah and I can't apparently talk
about Castle Rock because camp knows
nothing about it so throw your hands in
the air wave them like just don't care
bang I saw you with the glasses go ahead
stand up and oh they got a microphone
for you fantastic so we'll hear you on
the podcast what's your name young
shaver everyone give it up for Elliot
Elliot you are gonna swim in one of
these two XL t-shirts man but that
depends on your question what do you got
for us
fair enough I did my very first job
while I was in high school was it a
video store but to be fair those of us
who worked in a video store know that
we've never really worked in a video
store that's where we went to hide out
from work and smuggle porn home yes
in the town I grew up in is Bellingham
Washington just on the other side I was
just there I bought weed there the other
day soon as that crossed the border that
was the first place I stopped what's
called film is truth that is such a
pretentious video store name but I love
it oh my god you know you're gonna
[ __ ] get some good rentals at film is
truth of course I'm surprised it's not
in Latin
the only reason film is truth is still
open my question for you guys is the
ultimate movie about working in a video
store number one great [ __ ] question
you're gonna get a t-shirt um let me see
for me I mean look progress marches
forward and [ __ ] like that and if you
try to exceed I've tried to explain to
my kid I was like no you don't
understand
when we wanted a movie we'd get in the
car and we drive to a place and we'd go
to it like a library well a library
that's where they have books a book
that's where you know it's like suddenly
you're explaining something that makes
no sense and you realize you know as you
explain you're like no it was great we
would go we didn't know if we were gonna
get the movie we wanted because if we
didn't we could get something else and
that's how you have major discoveries
like I found movies that I never would
have watched if it weren't for the fact
that a new release wasn't in and bla bla
bla but you know she's of a generation
that's just like but wait you should be
able to get what you want whenever you
want it you know and it's like oh yeah
right here [ __ ] millennial so it's
it's sad for me on one level as a guy
who you know [ __ ] that's where I came
from it's weird watching video stores
disappear you feel a little bit like
kal-el you're like I'm the last son of a
dying planet you know it's just a weird
place to kind of exist particularly when
it was big fabric of a big part of the
fabric of your life then you stop to
remember it wasn't always there that
came in way later in life and it had its
wonderful run and [ __ ] but we're gonna
we're gonna see let's see I was part of
a generation they wrote pieces about it
like I remember this big variety piece
film school generation the video store
generation bunch of filmmakers came out
the video stores I was definitely one of
them Quentin Tarantino of course was
probably the most famous one Roger Avery
bunch of people a bunch of us worked in
video stores and there was an article
that they wrote in variety where they
talked about like all these movies are
dialogue driven why is that and my
suggestion was well when I was in the
store I'd put on a movie but I couldn't
always watch a movie but it was always
[ __ ] playing so it was always in my
head that's what a movie is to me is
mostly dialogue and stuff that will go
away like that won't exist that
happenstance of finding things and stuff
that way learning by accident backing
into the rest of your life that won't
really happen anymore and that's kind of
sad on the other hand though it'll
happen in a different way you know
somebody's gonna see something on
Netflix or let's be honest there you see
something on YouTube that inspires them
now like that's the thing that I found
out later in life in the age of YouTube
I've gone on some people shows and [ __ ]
like that and they're always very sweet
about like oh my god it's you and
they're way younger and they were never
around like when I was [ __ ] at my
prime in the beginning and [ __ ] like
that so I don't understand is it just a
sense of like oh I've heard that you
used to do things or something like that
but what it is it's a bunch of people
who are like [ __ ] clerks made me want
to do this like because you made that
movie I realized I could pick up a
camera and just shoot me and my friends
and even though I don't make a feature
like I went on and created a youtube
show because of that so
there's there people are people who are
hungry will get fed someplace else
sadly it won't be the way that we were
used to being fed or feeding others and
stuff like that the communal experience
of coming to a place and chit-chatting
with person behind the counter and [ __ ]
like that and hoping to get a movie just
kind of dissipates and goes away I'm
happy though that I do have a movie that
chronicles it cuz now my shits like a
historical document at the end of the
day like to prove the oh no people would
leave their houses to rent a movie can
you believe this [ __ ] but man it's
[ __ ] sad to see it go I mean I'll do
you one better though last time I was in
New Jersey I went to a quick check in my
hometown of Highlands and I went to
[ __ ] check out there wasn't even
human being it was a robotic [ __ ]
Clerk man so I was like well that's
[ __ ] too like both my [ __ ] man
convenience stores and video stores they
don't exist and they don't even need
humans anymore so I'm glad I could put
that [ __ ] on film when I did but it's
weird to see it go but you know at the
same time I can't be like I'm mad about
it cuz I never went back you know it's
not like I would love the video store so
much that I wasn't opened one myself and
stuff writing was on the wall last time
I walked into a video store a very small
storefront but brand new looked like
somebody just [ __ ] open didn't [ __ ]
and this was within the last year so I
had to you know I heard about it I was
the video store and like I think they
tweeted me they like pop by and I was
like who opens a [ __ ] video store in
this day and age when inside and the
dude there would be on the counter plays
a closet like smaller than rst video
from quick stop and [ __ ] and I was like
this is the dream and he was like this
was a dream man open a video store I
always wanted to do it and stuff you
know I was like but you're actually had
VHS is up on the wall not even DVDs like
but this is what I grew up with man he
goes but let me show you the special
feature and then he goes to the [ __ ]
new release section grabs one of the
[ __ ] tapes and pulls it it triggers a
lever and a wall opens up and what's
behind is a bar and so he's like that's
where we make the money man like so
what's the theme bars like but do you
actually rent the videos you have people
come in to rent him well random and [ __ ]
he's like there's some people they're
like oh thank god VHS and they come in
and rent all the time
he's going but whenever they Bible even
here they grab this movie like that
opens the door and [ __ ] that's the only
release thing I have available so it's
nice it's kitschy in some places in the
world and stuff but [ __ ] out sad to see
it go you I mean the thing the thing
that I missed from from the video store
generation was the idea of curation the
idea that there was a clerk there who
and it was part of your job to kind of
know what your customers wanted right
but also to know the thing that they
like that you know they would like yet
so it's hey you know you really like
Robocop let me turn you on to this thing
called hardware which you've never seen
before but this will be [ __ ] awesome
and and we're gonna go to this Peter
Jackson movie meet the Feebles which
you've never seen but it's also kind of
like that and then from there we're
gonna bounce the [ __ ] dark man
because I know you kind of like Sam
Raimi but you're also kind of like
superheroes you've never seen this what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you and it's and
it's it's learning to expand your mind
it's like it was like a movie Sommelier
right like a dude who knew oh you want a
little tannin in the backyard here and
you wanted a little fruity afterbite
here here's the movie for you you don't
know it yet but this is your new
favorite movie that doesn't exist
anymore we've lost that sense of
curation we've lost that sense of
surrendering yourself to not on an
algorithm but to a guy who kind of knows
who you are which sounds super [ __ ]
dirty but but that discovery that holy
[ __ ] here's the thing that I was never
going to see unless somebody recommended
to me you know and I also think that
consequently we've almost lost the cult
film you know like the thing that just
kind of came out and vanished until
three or four years later we all kind of
knew that hey you know you've never seen
crime wave have you know well now you
need to and then you're gonna see it
even turn out to a friend and then a
friend and then a friend and then a
friend that that almost you know almost
sexually transmitted passing of a movie
yeah doesn't exist in that same way
anymore I mean every now and again
there's all you gotta see the [ __ ]
babadook or oh man you really gotta go
see train to Busan or oh [ __ ] you gotta
go see this thing or the raid or
whatever it is but there used to be an
entire industry of cult movies and
things that we realized as cult movies
don't exist that way anymore and I I
missed that I missed that like oh [ __ ] I
mean I've never
so Princess Bride in the theater but now
it's a part of my life and it wouldn't
have been a part of our lives if it
hadn't been for a video store and so
that that entire economy of Kult feels
gone to me and that saddens me and I
wish it would come back I wish that VHS
would become like vinyl in the oh hey
you know that music you know that movie
you love would you like to see it in
like the worst [ __ ] quality ha ha
have I got a store for you here's a
thousand dollar VHS player and I'm like
the best shitty tube TV and you could
recreate the experience from 1883 I'm
sure some hipster in [ __ ] Brooklyn
already has that lockdown uh-huh but
like that would be kind of neat like one
of my favorite things to do is I still
have a bunch of old VHS tapes at home
but I used to use this like shelving
like I want to put a couple two by fours
on this stack of tapes and there's
pullin one off and popping in the
[ __ ] VHS which I still have connected
to some TV and watching the dumb [ __ ]
commercials from like 1983 between
episodes of like next generation that I
had taped what are they trying to sell
me here did burgnik you really have a
handicap mascot named wheels really
Burger King from herb to wheels to
wheels but that weird like pop
archeology like I'm taking [ __ ] deep
I'm I'm unearthing they hidden Arcana of
the past you can only do on VHS these
days you get it's time travel really and
I loved it about that and I wish that
there was a world in which I mean
YouTube is also that thing but you're
looking for it you don't stumble into oh
[ __ ] I bought that toy huh cool and
that's that's what I miss the most you
know what I didn't realize when I first
took that job but I I thought it was the
job of a lifetime because I was like
you're gonna [ __ ] pay me to like
watch movies like well technically no
like but that's all I heard I was like
video store oh my god I'm i watch movies
all [ __ ] day long and [ __ ] like that
even if I have to like wash the counter
down once a day they still can't stop me
from [ __ ] watching movies and I
thought that's what I wanted most about
that job but when I had the job what I
realized was that wasn't that was the
initial draw
like what could be better than that but
what I realized what could be better
than that is the area edition for the
first time in my life I can literally
offer opinion or talk about [ __ ]
knowledgeably that people were
interested in it wasn't just like oh my
god you're way too into movies like it
was a movie store the fact that I was
into movies was a benefit so you could
turn people on to [ __ ] and whatnot and
that was later fed by social media right
like at the end of the day now I could
jump online and show off my era edition
as opposed to just the 25 people that
would come through the door on the
average day at the video store
but back then that's where it began like
the idea of like oh [ __ ] like this
matters for years I was told knowing
this [ __ ] means nothing you're wasting
your time with this crap why do you know
all this why don't you learn your
schoolwork and show the sted of this and
suddenly there was a place where all
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] useful in the
real world like a job or knowing knowing
what buckaroo banzai isn't being able to
pass it off to somebody and [ __ ] got you
them coming in the next day being like
that was great you got any more than
like that and stuff like that so that
sense of self-worth something that I
took into my job for the rest of my life
like literally what are we doing up here
except the same [ __ ] I would do at the
video store [ __ ] with customers come
into all my opinion talk about like do
you see the [ __ ] picture of that
Joker and but this time it was Jack
Nicholson you know and [ __ ] like that so
it's the same thing that I found a
different venue for it like any you know
as much as I missed the video store I'll
be honest with you you cover more ground
online being like these are the thoughts
of my thoughts on movies but that's
where the bug first bit me that's where
I realized like oh [ __ ] I could be able
to talk about this like for real maybe
for a living you know eventually
graduate it to that place where like
this is what I do for a living I talk
about pop culture
that all started right there man that
place made me feel like I had something
to add to that conversation I grew up in
a world full of [ __ ] sports and I
never had anything to add to the
conversation other than boy that looks
hurty you know and [ __ ] like that so to
be in a world where suddenly like the
[ __ ] that I cared about like I didn't
have to belabour [ __ ] front you know
and grown up I had one [ __ ] friend
who loves Star Wars like I did and he
lived in New York he only came down for
the summers so the rest of the year I
would talk to people like hey man you
wanna play Star Wars they're like oh I
saw that movie once doesn't have a space
dog in it you know and I'm like you
[ __ ] heathen you know and so so it
like being able to sit in a place where
knowing stupid [ __ ] and talking about
movies was valued by the people that
would come in gave you a sense of like
important it's not self-importance but
like I said I'm finally part of the
conversation as opposed to outside of
the conversation so um I missed that
aspect of it as well it kind of grew me
it's it's where the person that you guys
know was first [ __ ] born really in
the video store boy that made us all sad
but you win a t-shirt give it up for our
man oh [ __ ] we need a [ __ ] cannon
that's a terrible throw on my behalf
Sports well done all right here we go it
supports you picked the next one uh
let's see where we gonna go over here
beautiful the microphone and pocket look
how excited you are about it man like
you want some you can even get a shirt
yeah what's your name young camper
everyone Jarrod hey Joe everyone give it
up for Jared man everything I've done
I've done for you yeah I mean that's a
that's a great question so you're gonna
get a shirt but be out my short answer
is Bruce Willis that was that and again
it's now I've had years passed and [ __ ]
now I'll play my part or whatever I went
there with high expectations cuz I was a
big fan of the man big fan of his work
going back to childhood and perhaps he
was unnerved by how much of a fan I was
or whatever the [ __ ] but the experience
as I've talked about many times it was a
tough one but that was mine yours
I wrote a comic book a while back called
genius
came out for image first issue came out
in 2009 and we finally finished it in
2014 but after the first issue came out
we got a little bit of interest from
Hollywood as happens and so the
production company that's currently run
maybe I don't know how much has to do
with anymore but by let's just call them
the biggest movie star on the planet
and it's not Tom Cruise decided they'd
like hey we'd like to take a run at this
and and my writing partner Adam Freeman
and I said get [ __ ] yeah of course like
let's let's have a talk about it let's
get on the phone and we'll have a
meeting and so we get on the phone with
them and in case you don't know what the
book is it's it's about you know in
every generation there is a military
genius what if our Napoleon or Hannibal
or Alexander the Great was a 17 year old
black girl from South Central who
decided to take on the LAPD and secede
four square blocks from the Union it's
about siege it's about police brutality
it's about devaluation of human life
it's about all those things but also
with [ __ ] explosions and gunfire and
helicopter attacks and all of that [ __ ]
and but it's very much rooted in the
place and in the time and in the
conflict like those things felt sort of
immovable for us and so this company
comes in and says hey listen we love the
book we really really do what if instead
of taking place in the present day it
took place in the future after like an
apocalypse like but but that's not the
book owner we loved the book the book is
amazing but what if instead of the LAPD
was also like Private Security and what
if it was like post earthquake so a man
like roving gangs and sounds like they
had something they wanted to do right I
wanted to graft your thing onto totally
or the we kind of like this we're afraid
of having a protagonist who's killing
cops so what if we sit made it like Mad
Max but like Mad Max in 24 at the same
time like what are their it's like Long
Beach private security instead of LAPD
and what if it's like everything's on
fire so it's opposed to Apocalypse and
we understand why people are pushed to
the brink and and you have to sit
through this meeting again
with the production company run by the
biggest movie star in the world and not
flip a table you know and not just like
[ __ ] you know buy if you want to buy the
book buy the book if you don't want to
buy the book and make that thing go make
the I'll go see that [ __ ] thing all
of those things I like just not for this
the reason why we all love this is the
very thing you're trying to bastardize
with that version of it so that that
sense of remembering that the only real
power we had in that scenario was know
like we still owned it it was still ours
if we said yes then we cede all
responsibility and all sort of any right
to complain if we said yes so we didn't
and it was like to have this yeah no I
understand I I see that version of it no
sure yeah I can that might work
maybe but not with us so yeah that was
not Bruce Willis but still a yeah you
got a [ __ ] light man I cried most
days that's a great question you want to
share give it up for our man all right
here we go hand up man you I saw you
first dead center what's your name while
you're walking over there
Lex [ __ ] a man I never met one in
real life give it up for Lex hey you got
your hair too oh right on man Bradford
that's the hometown of Wayne Gretzky
what the [ __ ] you're a Canadian you
didn't realize Jesus himself [ __ ]
threw your ball
Bharati Avenue right that's where that's
where he lives lived I'm you don't live
there anymore [ __ ] went dark there for a
second start yes he just loves acting in
general there there you have a to do
background work there's a [ __ ] agent
for everything man really does work them
[ __ ] like works were all right let me
see agents how do I feel about agents
I've had I've had a weird I've I've had
them for years since the beginning since
I got in this business so I'm in this
business coming up on
in January it will be 25 years so 25
years my relationship with agents been
all over the boards sometimes I'm just
like oh all they do is get your salary
up 10% so they can take that you know
[ __ ] like that that's the old man in me
crank when I say things but I have
wonderful agents the ones who booked me
in shows live shows like this am I not
Seth he's fantastic
I've got and my agent my key agent now
is a his name is Jordan Cerf but we call
him boy Jordan because we have a Jordan
in our company girl Jordan Jason muses
wife so boy Jordan who he hates here in
it but that's his name then damn it yeah
he always says that he goes I am a man
I'm like your boy Jordan and so boy
Jordan has been absolutely wonderful
he's got me like in two rooms four
amazing [ __ ] gigs that I can't talk
about yet and stuff like that so I I can
speak to agents being good when you're
out of place like I was already at a
place in my career where you know you
could kind of sell me easier if I'm an
unknown quantity you got to convince
people since I got a tail behind me they
could be like well [ __ ] you know
are you into Kevin Smith if so he's for
sale and [ __ ] like that
so see in the window Magilla gorilla so
so I've found that in my experience I
know there are some I've you know I've
known actors who've had agents who are
like [ __ ] devoted like they believe
in their client they're gonna take them
all the way and eventually they do and
stuff like that I've never really had
that nice I started my career with a
thing right like I had a movie to show
so suddenly people were like oh it once
once somebody bought the movie they're
like you are talented now and so they
were interested in representing me I've
never had an agent have to go out there
and try to like get work for me the
agents boys had it easy because I've
always been able to set up things that
I've wanted to do so that being said I
don't know if I'm the best person to
address it but I will say let me see it
was my best advice never pay somebody if
they're like you got to pay me to be
your agent
yeah but I mean from from your
percentages or you had to give when you
were kid
oh they [ __ ] to you there's a bit of
that too like it's like any other
business there's a junks and there's
things that are connected right so what
I've heard like my kid went through all
this fairly recently so I guess I can't
speak to it more knowledgeably over the
course of the last year she went you
know she after she graduated high school
she go and be an actress and so at one
point for her it was so [ __ ]
important to get an agent you know and
I'm her dad so I you know I want to tell
her like oh my god [ __ ] don't do it
like you don't need an agent like very
crazy [ __ ] like they only get you up
10% to take it away and [ __ ] like but
for her she's like you know hey man this
is like working actresses like you know
you go into an audition you got to have
an agent and [ __ ] blah blah blah so
she went on the hunt and at one point my
wife was like we got to go on a meeting
with her she's meeting with this agency
I've never heard of we should go to the
meeting and so I was like okay I mean I
was trying to let her do her own thing
so I don't want to [ __ ] step and like
you know that's her journey and bottle
upon I'm here to help and [ __ ] but like
I don't want to you know and she's like
do you want her to fall into the hands
of some creep odes and [ __ ] I'm like
well [ __ ] they're not all Creepo it's
they're just lazy and stuff so I was
like all right let's go meet with the
agency to see what they're all about and
so we met with them and it was really
fascinating to to be in that meeting cuz
it was you know I got to them not flying
the walks they can't ignore me I'm
obviously there and they're like oh [ __ ]
it's that guy but the pitch the rap the
cell that they gave my kid like you know
I got experience I've been in the
business almost quarter of a century so
to me it's just all [ __ ] hype and
words like they were sitting there going
like you know my agency the one I'm at
now they got me years ago I was a sucker
cuz they said this to me they're like we
work so hard we make money while you
sleep you go to sleep
we're making money for you you wake up
you got free money and I believe that
and so I was like you're my agents and
so they've never made money while I
sleep ever and so they were giving my
kid the money while you sleep pitch and
I was like I [ __ ] fell for this [ __ ]
20 years ago like but you know I gotta
let her make her decision she wants to
find her agency but I heard that one
point they had an agent come in yet -
who's adorable he had to [ __ ]
separate bluetooths in he was [ __ ]
busy you know what I'm saying so very
successful so he came in late like
everyone else was sitting there are
these new partners and this was a
startup agency a boutique agency
somebody had left one of the smaller
boutique agencies it's well known like
Gersh or something like that and went
and created their own boutique agency
I'm gonna tell you no Jerry Maguire I'm
gonna take my clients with me and treat
it like that and so there were a few of
them and they were all dudes which I
thought right away what a mistake you're
meeting a young actress you're gonna put
four [ __ ] dudes in a room like all
right thank God me and the wife are here
and so we're sitting there and and three
people are talking and pitching on their
new agency and how great it's gonna be
then the dude with two bluetooths comes
in sits down and [ __ ] like that he's
like the cool too-cool-for-school like
legend you know the [ __ ] he is he
basically he looks if you looked up
agent in a dictionary there's his
picture and [ __ ] so he sits down and he
goes let me tell you what we do because
he heard where we were in the discussion
goes this is what we do for you as an
agency and mind you this agency was
about 20 minutes old so like whatever
he's talking about it's not what they
can do it's what he's done in the past
maybe but this I found incredibly weird
he goes we don't just we get your we get
the client the part like we're not just
gonna like send your daughter out for a
part we're gonna get her that part and I
was like how do you do that and he's
like because what we do is we call
afterwards so she goes in for the
audition and then we spend the next two
weeks calling like crazy every day just
pushing and pushing the client so now
you know I'm like that works and they're
like you ask man cuz we advocate for the
clients such a big bad way we change
minds now I again I'm not bragging but
I've been in this business a [ __ ]
minute and [ __ ] like that and I've
casted movies over the course of my
career and
and nobody has ever changed my mind let
alone an agent gone like you got a
higher my client my clients right for
the part it's like you don't [ __ ]
know what I want so they've never let's
never in my experience and I've known
other filmmakers I've never heard them
say like well I wanted to guess this
person but this [ __ ] agent talked me
out of it and I cast their clients dead
never [ __ ] happen and that's what the
dude was selling in the room so you know
it was hard to not pipe up and be like
look if you did that like I'd never cast
your client then I would tell your
clients that they should drop you as
their [ __ ] agency but my wife looked
at me because I've leaned forward in the
seat and she goes like this
you know we're just here to observe you
know I I don't have any practical advice
but I can say this if you establish
yourself then at least you've got skin
in the game you've got the benefit of
knowing i generate the [ __ ] work and
stuff like that that's not the answer
you're looking for
you take over I I can't really speak to
what it's like as an actor because I'm
not entirely sure
for me it's I'm a person who creates
something like I'm gonna sit that I'm
gonna write a script and I'm gonna then
present that script to somebody who will
either believe in it or not or believe
in me or not as an actor you are you are
responsive like you are they're looking
for this I'm going to go and be this
thing for them and I'm not sure how you
can decide which agent can help you in
that in that manner you know I will say
that also having been in on casting
sessions the the weirdest thing is that
no matter how prepared you are as an
actor for an audition no matter how much
you believe in it no matter how much you
[ __ ] ran the lines and you found the
character and you believe in it you
probably will or will not get that role
in the first five minutes they see you
and it's it's it's merciless and it's
awful but it's like I know we've thought
about a guy with a smaller nose and it's
it's not in your control at all but
you're not like winning that part once
they have already decided based on
something you have no control over
whatsoever is is awful like it's
horrible I don't I don't I don't know
how you people do it but I will tell you
it advice
I will I will tell you I'll tell you
this story I I had signed with a
relatively big agency one of the two or
three big agencies in Hollywood and the
agent had who decided to take me on who
I didn't pay upfront cuz don't do that
that's the key walk away yeah do never
pay in a repair they can take a
percentage of what they make for you
what you make if they set up the job but
other than that no money should change
hands right so they said all right well
what do you want they read a pilot that
I wrote they really liked it they said
what do you want to do next and I says
well he was three or four ideas that I
have but here's the one that I really
believe in he was the one that I've been
I believe waiting my entire life to
write they said great go write that one
so I did I took like six months and I
wrote this pilot and and I loved it and
I loved it to death
and the the agents were like we don't I
don't we thought it was gonna be
something else and it's not that thing
and we can send it out but we're just
it's not we don't believe in it the way
you believe in it and so after like six
months of them kind of half-assed
representing me we had like to come to
Jesus meeting where it's all right
listen I'm pretty sure that the next job
I get it be a job that I get because I
know enough people and I believe enough
that I think that that the network will
work for me not like CBS but the network
of my people will work for me and they
said well part of our problem is that
you know the latest sample we just
didn't quiet respond to and we want to
be able to get you the jobs that you
think you're gonna get for yourself so
it's not working out four months later
so they dropped me kind of flat mutual
breakup is why I tell myself uh four
months later a buddy of mine again in my
network was like hey so these guys to do
in the Stephen King show and I'm pretty
sure they need you on that staff what's
your latest sample and this is well he
was the thing that I believe in more
than anything and he said I'd sent it to
me so I send it to him he sent it to
them they called me in for a meeting and
I get this job I get Castlerock because
a buddy of mine knew the guys and and
made that connection for me fast forward
eight months after that and I get new
reps because I I got Castlerock without
an agent like that just happened because
I knew a guy
I signed on with new reps they read that
pilot and says here's what's gonna
happen we're gonna go and sell this
thing in two months I said oh [ __ ] all
right if you say so
in two months we went out we pitched it
we sold it and then my new agent had
breakfast with my old agent who dropped
me and she was like yeah I really [ __ ]
blew it on that didn't I like yeah you
did you really did cuz you didn't
believe like find somebody who had your
pretty woman moment back and if you
scroll back through my Instagram the day
that I sold that that was my day of the
week post was [ __ ] like big [ __ ] and
they said like we just didn't believe
and that's the thing is find somebody
who believes in you find somebody who
believes in your work find somebody who
believes in your potential and then will
hit the ground for you and and try and
execute that vision to the best of it
but like get you in the room get you the
support do that I mean it doesn't work
for a Kiske gotta get there got apart
like that's not how that goes but
advocate for you because if somebody
believes in you and believe in your
potential immolation your in your
quality then they will regardless of the
size of the agency regardless of where
they're at if they believe then belief
is all that that's the only currency in
Hollywood really it's belief and money
but mostly belief yeah so find somebody
who believes find somebody who responds
to you and sees that no in five years we
can get you what you want it's gonna
suck for a while
it's gonna be hard for a while you're
gonna get more nose than yeses but in
five years we can make you something and
go at that person and don't pay them
anything until they make you money
what's your name lady person as you make
your way to the mic yeah Emily Elizabeth
give it up for Elizabeth man
I'm sorry Bros will get a chance what a
great question
whoo I'll go first I can go first the
first comic book I ever read was the
savage sword of Conan issue 107 if
you're not familiar with the savage sort
of Conan it is not a book you should
give to an 11 year old boy my dad knew
that I was kind of into like fantasy and
sword and sorcery and science fiction
and so he found the comic book shop in
the town of the new town we just moved
in and went in like bought some [ __ ]
thinking this guy had the [ __ ] he'll
love this stuff and he bought like
Sarasota Conan is like there's nudity
and beheadings and like crazy [ __ ]
sexual assaults that you should not even
be putting in the comic book but this
was 1982 and they didn't give a [ __ ] and
so he brings home this lake and it's in
the brown paper bag like you can't just
have this hanging out and so I open it
up in my brain [ __ ] explodes and I
then I still I found them like two or
three months ago
like this giant [ __ ] cardboard box
filled with these old Sarasota Conan
books and and it just for me I didn't
know that that's what comics could be
you know I was familiar with Superman
and Batman and and and spider-man but I
wasn't the reader of them that I would
be two or three years afterwards but
like that book was oh [ __ ] you're doing
this in comics oh [ __ ] they're not just
for they're not just for kids anymore
they never were just for kids you know
like the the idea that comics had been
some juvenile form of literature when
they would sell two and three and four
million copies at a clip not just kids
are buying him mmm oh my god I never
thought about that like come on Captain
America in 1973 was selling like seven
million copies an issue and wasn't even
that good then but yeah it was it was
sever sort of Honan that was that was
the book that for me got me to go to a
comic book store and and and thus began
a lifelong love I was let me see
five yeah five the late for cusp of
fiver just happened
around the time my fifth birthday my old
man worked at a post office sectional
center who's a stamp canceler so he was
a mailman but he didn't deliver mail he
was guy worked in a building and [ __ ] so
I'd be like my dad's a mailman no like I
never seen him deliver the mail I was
like oh he don't do that but so he was a
stamp counselor and stuff like that
Ana's he worked in shrewsbury which is a
few miles from where we grew up and
stuff so hah Nizam once a month he'd get
a [ __ ] haircut at this place Benny
the barber and [ __ ] cuz right by his
work so because of that that's where me
and my brother and my sister wound up
going all the time we would go to Vinny
the barber my sister would get a bowl
cut and [ __ ] like that
so Benny the barber experiences you know
barber chair like old timey and [ __ ]
like that but I was so young they put a
board across the arms of the chair so
that I sat on top of the board so
otherwise I'd be below the chair and he
couldn't cut my hair and [ __ ] so dad
takes us if any of the barber and it's
the name that has magic in my house
because I've heard it my whole life but
never seen it like dad would mom be like
where where he's like I just got back
from Benny she's like oh it looks good
knows her who's Benny mom penny the
barber and so you know that name had
magic one day I actually met Benny the
barber and [ __ ] he lived up to every
expectation I had he was like a muppet
come to life just a very colorful old
man and [ __ ] like that and very Italian
and and so we'd come into place and
whatnot and he be like comes it I'll get
the board out for the boy and put the
boy on the board on the chair and then
I'd sit on it so we got there second
time not even [ __ ] first time first
time I met then he got my haircut and
[ __ ] gave me a lollipop at the end of it
everything about it was amazing yeah
second time I went back there were
people ahead of me so we were sitting in
the waiting area in the waiting area he
had a little black and white rabbit ear
television and under it had magazine
pile and then right next to it comic
book pile now I was familiar with the
Super Friends of course from the TV show
and is familiar with Adam West Batman
that was in reruns but I'd never
actually seen the renditions in comic
books so the first comic book I ever see
pulled out from under the [ __ ] TV is
a issue of Hot Stuff the little devil
if you don't know the character he is
Richie Rich in hell he's basically a
little demon she's good demon right like
he's Casper he's the demon version the
demonic version of Casper Friendly Ghost
and [ __ ]
so BAE's a friendly demon so I was a
young Catholic boy that appealed to me
I'm like Satan so I read that right
after that second comic I read sad sack
which was a Beetle Bailey kind of
knockoff about life in the army I didn't
enjoy it because the military is beyond
my understanding and so I didn't catch
me the way Hot Stuff did so I made
halfway through and I went to put it
down what I saw when I went to put it
down was the third comic under it which
was a Batman I think it was it was the
issue it's very famous cover giant Joker
Batman kind of crucified on a playing
card and stuff like that classic cover I
forget which number it is right now
that was my first Batman I saw Batman on
the cover and I knew Batman from TV so I
was like Batman and so I dug into it and
it was everything it was of course I
think it was drawn by what's his [ __ ]
name
yeah I'm sorry somebody just said it yes
it was a Neil Adams so it was you know
this was an incarnation of Batman that I
wasn't used to he certainly looked a
little bit like the Superfriends version
although far more detailed but he didn't
look like the Adam West Batman that was
my Batman short ears and stuff like that
this was the Dark Knight detective but
that was the first Batman I ever put my
hands on read it from [ __ ]
cover-to-cover
fell in love with the format of a comic
book I was very familiar with comic
strips you know of Sunday newspapers and
[ __ ] like that and the regular week to
newspapers but comic books the structure
the letters column the ads in it
everything and the smell like it's I
think I'm like as I circled the drain
from this life one of the [ __ ] things
that'll flash through my memory is very
distinct is that smell of a comic book
old comic book particularly and they're
all kind of old at a certain point the
old paper they used to print on and
stuff all of it the gestalt of it made
me [ __ ] fall in love and stuff and so
from that point forward
would ask mom like can I have 50 cents
to buy this comic book well 25 at that
point can I have 25 cents buzz
they were that cheap when I was a kid
and my parents were so cheap they'd be
like we can't afford that you know so
yeah well you have television watch that
so it was it was a life-changing moment
then and I still remember the order of
them but the one that captured my
imagination was the most was the
superhero book I didn't keep reading hot
stuff and I never went back to sad sack
but the superhero concept I fell in love
with at a young age probably because I
was raised to believe in my own
superhero Jesus and so like I was
already kind of in the mode of luck good
is better than bad but what I loved
about is the same thing I still loved
about all the [ __ ] and they tell stories
about the worst thing in the world
happening the worst thing imaginable
sometimes [ __ ] you could never imagine
they [ __ ] throw at you and [ __ ] like
that and everyone's running from it as
they should all good thinking sensible
[ __ ] people and then for some reason
people dressed in the most colorful
outfits head toward it I love that I got
that when I was a kid I was like oh my
god they're [ __ ] doing the right
thing like this it just appealed to me
and a big bad [ __ ] way and Morse
became my moral barometer more so than
the Catholic Church I was raised in
because that was a bunch of rules you
got to do this and if you don't you're
gonna [ __ ] go to hell and [ __ ] a lot
of threats and whatnot the reading
stories in the comics gave you the moral
barometer taught you that doing the
right thing was the right thing to do
without giving you like the heavy-handed
kind of or else and punishment to it so
I honestly feel like my moral barometer
came more from reading comics than being
raised in the church I was an altar boy
so I saw behind the curtain I know how
to sausage is made and [ __ ] so comic
books did it more for me
don't touch it don't touch it just let
it sit there you're not making it any
better don't you touch it
Did you touch it yeah pivotal moment in
life you answered I answered
that's a great question you get a
[ __ ] t-shirt well done you're gonna
fit 9 are you into that t-shirt man here
make a small tent from it all right we
got one t-shirt left and it's a red
version of the one I'm wearing
Mia's three pop characters that I've
portrayed in real life yeah you pick it
yeah
who wants it [ __ ] bad man that ain't
good enough yeah you think so you're not
guaranteed well I mean but you got to
ask the question you do but to sit down
here I got [ __ ] it
I want guarantees all right man what's
your name I won't give a f--- Andy you
want to be FS I give right up to the mic
so we can all hear hmm that's the
question I have Miss Marvel or work
Captain Marvel Kamala Khan okay um I
think there's there's this great clip
that circulated online a couple days ago
that I'd Sigma boosted because I loved
it and it was basically was a supercut
of and it was called like the the female
age of superheroes oh I watched that and
it's [ __ ] awesome and granted it's
just again you're just stealing like the
most amazing images from the most
amazing movies some of my favorite
filmmakers in the world are people that
put those clips together a hand [ __ ] in
YouTube where they're just like I went
through every superhero movie and put
all the girl superheroes together and
you roll a [ __ ] tear you're like
you're doing the Lord's work but I think
that when you see stuff like that and
when you're especially confronted with
the totality of it
you begin to realize that there are
people who have never seen themselves on
screen and never seen themselves
centered in these stories on screen and
so - at some point present into the
world a story about a female Muslim
superhero from jersey represent that
changes minds that that that shifts
perception it alters in many cases the
path that somebody's life can go down
because they never might have thought
that that was possible for them and then
granted they will not turn themselves
into female Muslim superheroes because
it's fiction but the sense that this
stuff is for you as much as it is for
anybody else that Hollywood is finding
value in you is is powerful it's really
powerful it's it's a sense of worth that
some people don't have there was a there
was a great video clip of when Black
Panther came out and it was a couple of
kids standing under like a black panther
poster couple black kids I think they
were in Baltimore or something and one
of these kids looks up at the poster and
says is this what white people feel
every day it's to tell you kid no but
when the world has not been calibrated
for you and suddenly there's a glimmer
of you in the world that matters in a
big bad [ __ ] way and there was
another not tunnel bum black panther but
there was a commercial for a black
panther toys and so they had this kid
[ __ ] running around playing with
friends whatever and the kid lifts the
Black Panther mask and it's a white kid
and to understand what that means to
understand the sense that hey there's a
little white kid out there tomorrow who
wants to pretend to be a black kid is
phenomenal for little black kids who've
been told for years nobody really wants
to be you look at the rest of the world
nobody wants to be black come on we are
black we don't want to be black but that
sense that there's a there's value the
world sees in you I think is
tremendously important and if that movie
gets made I think that it alters lives
and I think
that's no small feat keV I will never
forget going to see Wonder Woman with my
wife now I cry at the drop of a hat
I'm a middle-aged stoner everything
touches me and stuff so you know I see
superhero movies I see superhero
trailers and I get emotional like the
wound up working on the flash because I
put up a video of me crying watching the
season finale of season 1 and stuff so
I'm I'm a mark I'm a sucker for this
this [ __ ] makes me sweeps my heart's
breathtaking makes me [ __ ] cry my
wife she rolls her eyes that most of the
[ __ ] that makes me emotional and whatnot
like and she knows whenever I come into
the room out of nowhere and come sit at
her desk years ago boy what a Batman do
now you know she's like I've taken an
interest in Batman so she's not a mark
for this [ __ ] she don't really get into
it and you know Wonder Woman she was
like I'll go to that and I was like
really like I go to all these Marvel
movies she really won't God dragged her
through infinity war I was like this is
[ __ ] important and she did at the end
she was like I you know what I really
liked that it was like right right I was
like what's the rest with me she goes
I'm good and so so we went to see Wonder
Woman and you know when I'm when I [ __ ]
three minutes four minutes into the
movie like you know we're on the mascara
ah I feel the chair to my right and
hence mine cuz they're butted up against
each other
vibrating and it's not one of those 40x
theaters where the chair is supposed to
vibrate and [ __ ] and I look over and my
wife is bawling bawling [ __ ]
shuddering crying so hard that she's
like doing that [ __ ] [ __ ] but like a
weird not like oh my god are you hurt
joyful cry so I was like you're right
she goes you have no idea how long I
waited to see something like this she's
like never had this she's close as I
ever had was Princess Leia firing a gun
in Star Wars
at which point my daughter was like Shh
and we stopped talking
and then after the movie that's all
we've I could talked about she was like
oh my god I love the movie I was like
look I really liked it too but that
third act man with [ __ ] like you know
with you know that was kind of like a
Zack Snyder and she looked at me like
how dare you you just spit on history
and I was like oh I Spit I just thought
you know at the end it turned into the
standard she was like there's nothing
standard about that she's going you get
to go to a movie any day the week and
see yourself up there I was like they
don't put fat guys in costumes she's
like you know what I'm talking about you
got representation she's gone
that was incredible if I'd had that when
I was a child if I could see that that's
what was possible that like I wasn't
meant to be somebody's [ __ ]
girlfriend in a movie or a mark or
something like that she's like oh my god
what would it have what would the
difference it made so I remember that
like you know is kind of a weird moment
for me a wake wake and I'm the woke I
became a little woke at that moment
because I was sitting there going oh
[ __ ] like I take for granted that
everybody sees movies the same way I do
but clearly that was never the case so
yes if they can make a version of MS
marvel that is the version of Miss
Marvel that you know people are like man
[ __ ] I've never seen that before isn't
that a good thing like at the end of the
day of course it's an absolutely good
thing I support that 100% but nobody's
asking me except you
thank God man well done and that got a
great answer out of him so that gets a
[ __ ] shark BFS forever man oh my god
folks [ __ ] that went late we are out of
news and we're out of [ __ ] shirts to
give away so that means the show at 11
o'clock is that an end lady's gonna head
you have a good time this evening I
can't thank you enough for coming out
thanks especially to the REO for finding
space for us to do the show and whatnot
while the movies are going on and stuff
but there is the person we got to thank
the most man as the person in my left
there is no show without the guy sitting
next to me give it up for marvelous Marc
Bernardo
you guys and that is fat man beyond for
this week I'm Kevin Smith I am mark
Minard
tune in next time same bat time same bat
Channel smart guess taka more
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith Batman
Forever goodnight kuba
[Applause]
[Music]
you